thank you for tuning in for council of
geeks for our first ever panel
discussion I'm gonna be joined today by
Paul Skye Vito and Ryan Daly the
co-creators of the webcomic red and
green thanks for showing up guys thank
you now today we're gonna be talking in
general terms about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so why don't we start with the
obvious question favorite Marvel movie
so far it's really hard but I probably
say Captain America really the Avengers
would be a very close second but in
terms of just a solo action-adventure or
superhero movie I really enjoyed Captain
America so much so that I II and I think
we both agree on this the first hour of
the movie before he gets his powers is
one of the more compelling superhero
origin stories I think the fact that
they decided to go period with it was
really really important and also just it
looked cinematically it just looked
really good I thought Steve Rogers
character portrayals Ryan said it was
really good one of the things I think
that they got right with him in that
movie is that the sort of genuineness of
him of the character and that you know
he you know he's eager to please he
wants to do the right thing the scene in
the alley you know were you know they
sort of established that you know motif
for him that he's gonna keep getting up
the fake grenade scene you know the just
those little character points I just and
he's a different Captain America and I
think Captain America is different than
a lot of Marvel superheroes or a lot of
Marvel characters he's a good person and
I think Marvel heroes for the most part
are all kind of anti heroes not in the
way that the sort of 90s defined the
term antihero which is a good guy who's
willing to do really bad things who's
willing to kill people and a sort of bad
role model but it's still sort of
portrayed as a hero no an antihero in
the true sense that you wouldn't expect
somebody with this kind of personality
flaw to be the good guy if you're going
to give somebody a billion-dollar war
suit that can fly in fire missiles is
your first choice the alcoholic
womanizer with
like a five Narcis and no probably not
if you've got somebody who can do all of
the things that a spider can can do
you're gonna give that to the teenage
science nerd
mmm that wouldn't be my first choice but
that's also what made them so great
characters so the fact that the movie
did portray Captain America as not
necessarily having those character flaws
that he was as good as you would expect
him to be you know let's back up and
actually get a little bit of context
with this you're sort of history with
reading comic books Marvel in particular
was it something you did more as a kid
do you still keep up with it where does
that all fall with you guys I'm
definitely a kid if I read more and then
a friend
essentially waterboarded me with
kindness for a while to bring you down
so I got I back into the world of marble
I didn't I wasn't really reading for a
long time but I started reading my first
comics in the late 80s and never really
stopped for a short period of time or I
would I would drift and do sort of more
sophisticated graphic novels but part of
it part of me always came back to the
superhero genre just something about the
the American mythology of that that I
that I couldn't really find in any other
form of entertainment or literature I
couldn't find those characters or that
types of story in books or movies until
the last decade or so
Captain America we are going to be going
to see them will be opening I will be
having something on here about that but
I'm going into it and now I have to ask
since we know Toby Jones is coming back
to play our man Zola what are you hoping
for in terms of of how he's gonna look
the geeky part of me wants to see his
face on a robot such as boy with a with
a video camera as the head I want that
classic sort of crazy Jack Kirby Arnim
Zola I I'm sure won't happen if Marvel
is willing to do weird stuff yeah and I
there are he's not the only character
from that movie who's coming who's
making a comeback appearance and this
woman as I've heard so we'll see I don't
want to spoil too much yeah that gets a
little bit into spoilers and we'll try
to avoid that but looking ahead to what
we know is coming down the
like we've got guardians of the galaxy
now I have to wonder for me it's like
they make the decision that they were
gonna do fan OHS and then somebody in a
meeting said well if we're doing fan oh
so I guess we have to open up the whole
galactic cosmic side of Marvel what
property do we have that could do that
guardians of the galaxy works
I mean honestly I think that that was
part of the Avengers hits right part of
me wants to believe they just greenlight
everything that was in development
they're like what have we got we've got
a raccoon with a rocket yeah sure thing
yeah this go everything everything's ago
uh-huh and there was a script that's
these more cynical side of me I guess
but I I nearly did a spit-take when I
heard it was it was like a wait what
because I very well-versed in the Marvel
Comics and even that was one where I was
like I've read a few of these and I
wasn't crazy about them and even think I
was like okay if they're gonna open this
up to the Marvel cosmic side of the
universe
there's three or four characters haven't
think of before these guys I would think
out of morale are myself Froy go small
Captain Marvel the guy named Captain
Marvel space fighter I think that's one
of the things that did impress me was
the fact that morale did seem with that
with the trailer that came out they did
seem to acknowledge the fact that you're
not supposed to have ever heard of these
guys and they are just this crazy right
headbutt and part of that is the humor
fact that they're going yeah right but
who's a character that you would like to
see appear in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe that we haven't seen yet that
has not been announced or even really
hinted at whether they just show up as a
cameo or whether they get their own will
be who do you want to see that's it
Squirrel Girl
hands down they've got the entire story
laid out in my head that would work so
we'll put your email up on this Marvel
Kingdom gonna drop you a line random wow
that's hard to that's hard to [ __ ] I
would like to see fewer white men be the
stars of these movies I would really
love to see a Black Panther movie and I
that's that's been in development for a
long time it's been off and on for a
while I hope that comes true just
because I would like to see that he's
one of my favorite characters on that
I'm not ever sure why I just always like
to care if he's he's sort of the closest
thing to Marvel's equivalent of Batman I
would really love to see a female-driven
euro movie give Black Widow a solo movie
it's the easiest thing in the world you
take one of the Bourne movies and you
just put Scarlett Johansson in it and
everybody watches see for me I know
exactly who would be it would be
she-hulk
but like a single green female exactly
where she's she's the lawyer it's Ally
McBeal it's a David E Kelly so I can
play superhero law and that would just
be awesome if there's one complaint that
I could level against the Marvel
Cinematic Universe it's also one of the
things that I think makes us so
successful is that all of the movies
feel very similar in sort of they're all
the same genre even Captain America is a
world war 2 story as a sort of war story
was a superhero story Thor you've got a
character coming down from a different
level but it wasn't really a fantasy it
wasn't a lord of the Rings or Hobbit
movie it was a superhero story it had
the same kind of same kinda genrih
having said that I think the next
Captain America movie has the
opportunity to sort of break that that
sort of genre mould
I think the way when the Dark Knight
first came out the way people said it's
not just a superhero movie it's more of
a crime epic like The Godfather were
like he just happens to have a guy
running around in a cape I think this
Captain America movie the Winter Soldier
will have some of the similar things
said about I think they were really
building out it is going to be a
conspiracy movie it is going to be a
political thriller just happens to have
a guy wearing tights and throwing the
flag on the shield
you know I think thing is Marvel really
kind of has to start finding ways to
tell stories that aren't necessarily
just superhero stories because you know
eventually as much as I hate to say it
audiences are gonna start getting bored
with this so if if this is your staple
of characters that you have to work from
you've got to start finding other Jean
to work in thanks so much for stopping
by a guy from thank you for having us
red and green it's online